hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
today we will be learning about load
testing with jmeter
let us first have a quick look on the
agenda for today's session
we shall begin with learning the basics
of load testing and what is its
relevance
then we shall learn the different tools
that are used for load testing
after that we shall focus on one such
tool that is j meter
then we shall see some reasons why we
should use jmeter to perform load
testing
finally we shall see the process to
perform load testing
in both graphical user interface and
non-graphical user interface mode
in jmeter but before we begin
make sure that you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and click that bell
icon so that you can never miss an
update from
simply learn so without further ado
let's get started with the first topic
that is
what is load testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior
when a large number of users access the
application together
here performance testing is a software
testing process
used to test the speed response time
stability and reliability of the
software application
under a particular workload the testing
determines a system's performance
according to real life conditions
to give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer
so you want to test a printer by
transferring large number of documents
for printing
or test a mail server with thousands of
concurrent users
or to test a word processor by making a
change
in a large volume of data this helps to
know whether the existing infrastructure
is capable of running the application or
not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle
the testing identifies the limitations
due to hardware like cpu maximization
network bottleneck memory limitation etc
and it also identifies the issues in
software configurations such as
web server application server database
server
etc it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components
load testing is conducted to determine
the number of concurrent users
that an application can support without
performance deterioration
the response time of each transaction of
an application
and the network delay between the client
request and server response are also
checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to determining
user demands and satisfaction
several tools make load testing possible
such as
apache geometer web load load ui
load runner neo load load ninja etc
here in this session we shall be using
jmeter for load testing
so jmeter or apache geometer is open
source software
that is 100 pure java application the
application
is designed to load or test functional
behavior and measure performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against
heavy load multiple and concurrent user
traffic
it was originally designed for testing
web applications but has since expanded
to other test functions
to simplify let us assume that someday
your team leads
tell you to perform performance testing
for some websites like yahoo.com or
google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind do you think it's
practically possible to arrange
100 people with 100 computers and access
the internet and
accessing the same website now just
imagine the infrastructure requirement
when this testing has to be done for
thousand or ten thousand users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates
it will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server
group of servers network or object next
let's have a look at some reasons why
jmeter is used for load testing
we have divided these reasons into six
parts it is
free of cost performance testing of
applications
platform independent customizable
recording and playback
and community support now let's see all
of these
one after the other the first one free
of cost
one of the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost
normally a software can range from high
as
six to seven figures per license here
jmeter is free of cost very intuitive
and has all the possibilities you need
to automate your work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like
web applications web servers ldap
database and shell scripts jmeter can
conduct
load and performance test for many
different server types like
web http and https database via jdbc
ldap and jms the third important reason
is it's platform independent in nature
jmeter is written
and developed using java programming
language to run on any environment or
workstation
that accepts a java virtual machine for
example windows
linux mac etc the next reason we have is
jmeter is highly customizable since
jmeter is an open source application
it enables developers to customize it
whenever needed
jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler
and cleaner and adding and defining
elements is more intuitive
also one screen shows you everything you
need the script the scenario and the
analysis
the samplers are highly customizable
when determining which request is to be
sent to a host
however samplers don't enable full
control of test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback
the application provides record and
playback options enabled with the drag
and drop features making the application
faster
and easier the next and the last reason
in our list is incredible community
support
jmeter is an open source tool with a
brilliant community that
keeps adding features and supports users
who run
into issues and problems this ensures
new users always have someone to answer
their questions
and long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter
also having an open source tool ensures
it keeps
getting better and always in line with
users needs and requirements
now after we know about jmeter and the
reasons to use g meter let's understand
the process to perform
load testing with a hands-on demo the
only thing
that is kept in mind before this demo is
we must have a fully functional j meter
on our system
and by now we know that j meter can be
used in any operating system like
linux windows mac os and ubuntu
in this demo we shall look into both the
graphical user and non-graphical user
interface mode
of load testing so the first step is we
shall go to the apache geometer folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the jmeter.pad file
double click on this file this might
take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side
the elements of the test plan are added
and on the right side
all the configurations of the element
that are added as we are on the test
plan element
we can see the configurations of the
scene here the test plan is like a place
or a container where
all the elements we will use to perform
this test will be stored
all the requests the listeners and
everything will be stored here
so the first step is to add listeners
for that go to test plan
right click on the test plan go to add
then go to threads users and select a
thread group
the test group refers to the users that
are used or created or
needed to run this test it has several
different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose
it the way you want then there is this
number of threads where you can choose
the number of users you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's heads
then the third one there is a loop count
where you can choose
how many times the test will run for the
number of users
you can also choose the test to run
infinite times there is also a scheduler
here to help you
schedule the start time and the test and
time
for now let's leave everything to be
only one
the next step is to add the http request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option
and go to the http request option here
on the screen
there is a server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip in
that
let's pick a website and place the link
in that box we shall use the simply
learns website here
go to simplylearn's website and copy the
url from there
now we have copied the simply learns url
now let's come back to the jmeter window
and paste it in the server name box
keep in mind that we don't need to give
up the http or https since these are
protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the http request
case
so this is what i was talking about now
let's rename this name as
simply moving forward let's create one
more http request
for that again right click on the thread
group select samplers and select http
request and go to simply learns website
again
and there we have the resource link go
to that link and copy the url then
place that url in the server or ip
address box
we shall remove the http from that link
and add
from the end cut the resource part and
paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the http request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more http
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the http request option again to
add one more link to the server and ip
address
go to simply lens website go to the
corporate training link now
copy the url and go back to the jmeter
window and paste that url in the ip box
now cut the corporate training part from
the link and paste it to the
other path box
we shall again rename this http request
box as corporate
now let's save this file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
load testing dot
jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is
used to provide the outputs of the load
test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins the listener
we will use
here is the tree as it is comparatively
easy to interpret for that right click
on the thread group
then go to add select listener option
and
we go for the view results in tree
option now it's time to run the test and
check the load
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button
here to run second is you can go to the
run option and choose the run test
and the third is the way you can right
click on first geometer and then choose
run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to the
check the results of the test
in the view results entry section we can
see the green symbol that states the
test has
successfully completed since we had left
all the values to be
one in the beginning that's why there is
just one test for each http request now
let's increase the load
and let's change some numbers let's make
the number of threads to be 10
ramp up the periods to be 2 and the loop
count to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed
since we have increased the number of
users and ramp up the periods and the
loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count
now was 10 for each user the test will
run
10 times so here on the screen we can
see the time taken and the number of
tests being performed on the status of
each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode
now perform the same test in
non-graphical user mode we shall remove
the listener so
let's remove the view results in tree
after this we will go to the command
prompt then in the command prompt
we shall put the bin folder path in the
apache geometer folder
let's go to the bin folder and copy the
location from here now paste the path in
the command prompt and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing
this command has got three parts the
first part is the hyphen
n hyphen t and hyphen l here the hyphen
n represents the non
graphical user interface mode hyphen t
is used to specify the location of the
test script hyphen l is used to specify
the location of our output result
now go to the location where our jmx
file is stored
let's search for the load testing.jmx
file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the
name of the file with dot gmx
now go back to the folder and make a dot
csv file
make an excel spreadsheet and rename it
with dot csv
extension now copy this path and go back
to the command prompt
and paste it after the hyphen l in the
path don't forget to add
the name of the csv file towards the end
then execute the command
and wait for the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see
that the tree is successfully created
and towards the end of that execution
you can see that the message is the end
of the
run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file
in that file you can see the entire test
result has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the
load testing is successful in the non
graphical mode without any
errors this is what we had in this demo
we saw the load testing in graphical
user interface and non-graphical user
interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include
several graphs that explain the working
of the website link
we use in the http request the dashboard
generator is a modular extension of
jmeter
its default behavior is to read and
process samples
from a csv file to generate html files
it generates the report and at the end
of the load
test are on demand the dashboard reports
provide metrics like
the apd-ex or application performance
index
the dashboard also provides a statistics
table response time over time response
times
percentiles over time active threads
over time and response times in
percentiles
we shall learn about dashboards and more
in the forthcoming videos
in this video we learned how critical is
load testing in the software testing
process and
how it ensures high user satisfaction a
successful load testing
will help to release high quality
software and
so with this we have come to the end of
this session i hope you guys found it
informative and helpful
if you have any queries and questions do
let us know in the comment section below
thank you for watching stay tuned for
more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn nerd up and get certified
click here